13 dólares mensuales es el salario
promedio de un trabajador público
venezolano según la consultora a nova la
hiperinflación de los últimos 3 años y
las consecuencias económicas del cob y
19 están ahogando a la economía
venezolana el gobierno ante esta
situación ha dejado de sancionar el
absentismo laboral hoy en día en el
hecho público del trabajo público como
tal pues o renuncian a uno de esos de
esos cargos o sencillamente ni siquiera
la renuncia la procesa hoy te abandonan
y se dedican a este a lo informal
además de absentismo venezuela continúa
en un éxodo que no termina tras el
abandono de más de 5 millones de
personas
una ola migratoria que lleva a muchos al
límite como demuestra el reciente
naufragio en el que fallecieron al menos
23 venezolanos cuando trataban de llegar
a trinidad y tobago hay que exigir la
respuesta clara y contundente a trinidad
y tobago y hay que exigirle respuesta
clara a un estado que finalmente ante la
situación pero tampoco aquellos que
consiguen llegar a otro país logran una
mejor vida en perú por ejemplo la
pandemia dejó sin trabajo al 89 por
ciento de venezolanos muchos quedaron
sin casa otros volvieron a venezuela y
algunos como lilia gutiérrez pasaron a
vender de forma ambulante en la calle
realmente no me gusta pero tengo que
hacerlo y ha buscado trabajo y me han
dicho que por ser venezolano no nos
quieren aceptar pues ni en venezuela ni
migrando una encrucijada para millones
de personas mientras la crisis política
interna del país y las sanciones
económicas parecen perpetuar una
situación anormal
que tras haberse reutilizando cada vez
se siente más normal entre los
venezolanos